er well you talk about that in your book
this is it island atkins will she do act
one of her life on stage it's out now
and i mean how do you describe the book
heidi
uh well i think i can describe it very
easily because now you and i have a
great friend miriam margulies oh lovely
mirror
yeah and she's just had a wonderful book
out
and
my book
is
very very
i mean my book is very like miriam's
except that i'm not gay i'm not jewish
and i don't do that charity work of
giving [ __ ] to men
so my book is a hundred pages short
and that's a good summation
well yes that's that's on the back
but
in the book in the book you you describe
a childhood in the second world war and
it's so
my sister was watching this
but you describe a childhood during the
second world war and it was
extraordinary because your father
sounds like an extraordinary man well
my father was taught
i was five when the war started and my
father was told
by some neighbor i missed stratkins you
don't have to look like a adolf you
could really pass for adolf
and my father always wanted to perform
so
i mean nobody else would have done it
but he
uh got the little moustache
and he slicked his hair down and he was
a a meter reader
and an electric meter reader so he had a
uniform
he had the full thing and um he did it
so well that one day he was reading a
meter in hackney
and he uh came back home and he said um
well i had quite a day today
um
reading the meter
big woman in acme
pushed me from behind into the cupboard
locked the door got the police in
said she'd got adolf disguised
[Applause]
and he was proud of him
[Music]